the whole freaking thing is crashing
here is peter ducey of fox news as you
know he is one of the few journalists
that i don't have to put air quotes
around when i say the world journalist
and he's doing just a bang-up job at
these white house press briefings here
he is talking to karine jean-pierre she
is the black lesbian who replaced jen
saki uh about what's going on with this
stock market situation president biden
once bragged about the stock market
hitting record after record after record
on my watch how about now
meaning the stock market
all the gains from president biden's
time in office have been wiped out
so
as you know we're watching we're
watching closely
we know families are concerned about
inflation in the stock market that is
something that the president is is
really aware of and so look we face
global challenges we've talked about
this
this is we're not the only country
dealing
with what we're seeing at the moment as
it relates to inflation you know putin
putin's price hike inflation coming
coming
out of a once in a generation uh global
pandemic all all of those things play a
factor but we are coming out of the
strongest job market in american history
and that matters and that a lot of that
is thanks to the american rescue plan
which only democrats uh voted for that
republicans did not and it led to uh
this this economic boom that this
historic economic boom that we're seeing
with john historic inflation
no that is not that is that is that is
not uh
that is not how we're seeing the
american rescue plan god you gotta love
it guys they're paying attention to it
don't worry families aren't concerned
don't worry and then the end of that is
just so absolutely perfect it's the
democrats who voted for the economic
disastrous thing that caused all of the
inflation or as she calls it an economic
boom it is their party that did all this
and the republicans who voted for it
right so this is completely bipartisan
criticism if you are a pathetic i don't
i don't know that i've ever said the
phrase rhino but if you are a rhino
republican and name only republican who
voted for
the recovery and to basically demolish
the economy because that's what biden
and the democrats wanted this thing is
on you
too but what's the theme here that it's
starting to show it really is starting
to show and they are starting uh to be
unable to hide the fact that things are
not going well and it's really getting
pointed on the old man uh here's more
from rnc research
breaking biden's approval rating has
dropped below 40 for the first time
according to 538 now 538 like these are
basically lefties okay these are this is
basically a progressive polling
organization it's certainly a democrat
progressive polling organization it's
run by nate silver who is a lefty uh so
this is not like i'm going to some
republican polling thing and seeing if
they like biden or not this is the
simple fact that they cannot hide this
much more and uh now corinne jean-pierre
is being pressed on the fact that nobody
likes joe biden uh most presidents i'm
guessing would say don't pay attention
to the polls
um but does president biden feel any
concern that his approval rating is is
really pretty amazingly low and
consistently low i believe today went
under the average and under 40
first time the president's focus on
delivering for the american people
that's his focus right now
meaningless dribble
oh he's focused on that well is he
focused in the right way has he
you know maybe hired someone who's
competent who could help with the
economy instead of bringing on all these
social justice warriors and woke people
and trans activists to do other things
other than you know make things right
could he try any of that uh so then this
got peter ducey to follow up the natural
follow-up
[ __ ] ain't good so is the guy going to
stick in this thing or what quickly is
the president running for re-election
he has ant
first of all
let's reset for a second i cannot talk
about uh elections i cannot be a
political analyst from here uh or uh you
know or the midterms or anything like
that or including 2024 the president as
you know has been asked that question
many times and he has answered it uh his
answer has been pretty simple which is
yes he's running for re-election i can't
say more than that all right so first
off i don't know what she's talking
about that she can't answer questions
like that she is the press secretary i
mean
you're the [ __ ] artist in chief
that's that's what it is that's what a
press secretary does whether you like a
press secretary or not a press secretary
is supposed to do the pr right the press
secretary is supposed to
you know give the best front forward
facing
facade front forward facing facade
to whatever it is that you're doing on
any given topic so she can't talk about
that then she kind of muddles through it
and then yeah he's running he's running
and it's like we all know he's not
running everyone knows he's not running
it will be a miracle if he finishes this
thing